[موسيقى]
لذا فإن النفايات الإلكترونية موجودة في كل مكان، إنها
مشكلة كبيرة ولكنها أيضًا فرصة
[موسيقى] كبيرة،
لذا لديك هنا في هذه السيارة
العديد من الأمثلة لديك لوحات دوائر،
ولديك أجهزة كمبيوتر محمولة وهواتف محمولة أيضًا  سيئة للغاية
لأنه من الواضح أنه يتم
التخلص من الملايين منها دون إعادة تدويرها، لذا في
نهاية المطاف تسلط هذه السيارة الضوء على
المشكلة الجديدة ولكن بالطبع صنعناها في
شكل سيارتنا الخاصة في النهاية،
ما يهمنا حقًا هو
تسريع الانتقال إلى
التنقل الكهربائي المدعوم بالطاقة المتجددة،
هذا هو ما تدور حوله مجموعة U Envision
وتصور السباقات، لذا
من أجل المتعة فقط نصنع هذه السيارة لتعمل فعليًا
حتى تتمكن من قيادتها بوضوح ليس
بنفس سرعة سيارة السباق الرسمية التي لديك
مثل المخاوف المتعلقة بالسلامة  ولكنه يعمل،
هناك نموذج كهربائي وبطارية
ويمكننا في الواقع قيادتها، لقد فعلنا ذلك
في سباق الفورمولا إي في
لندن، هناك العديد من الطرق لحلها أو
على الأقل العمل من أجل
إدارة أفضل للنفايات الإلكترونية وبالطبع
النوعية  بالنسبة لمستوى التنظيم، تعلم أولاً أن
هذا يحدث بالفعل من خلال
محاولة إنشاء المزيد من المعايير، لذلك
هناك نوع من الخطوات التنظيمية التي
يتم اتخاذها لمحاولة السير في
الاتجاه الصحيح ولكن بالطبع يكون الأمر على
المستوى الجماعي على
المستوى الفردي  أنه يمكن حقًا أن يحدث
فرقًا، هناك
الكثير من الأشياء الإلكترونية التي لا يمكن إعادة تدويرها، وفي
النهاية، في كل مكان تقريبًا في جميع أنحاء
العالم، يمكنك العثور على طرق لإعادة
تدوير أجهزتك الإلكترونية، وهذا
كما قلت له ميزتان رئيسيتان
أولاً بالطبع من أجل البيئة ولكن
ثانيًا من الناحية الاقتصادية، ونحن
بحاجة فقط إلى بذل الجهد والقيام بذلك
[موسيقى]